so we're living in an ERA with multiple
overlapping disruptions that business is
facing and I want to dive straight in
and talk about one of the biggest of
those which is AI how are you
approaching AI you know AI at scale
there's it's a whole big subject of
course but for us at sopi we aim to be
the world's leading pharmaceutical
company using AI at scale why and how
are we going to do that it's pretty
straightforward we have 23,000 people
using AI uh as often as every month
9,000 people in the company using AI as
often as every day we boldly taking on
the opportunity to completely disrupt
the business we don't have a choice it's
the fourth Industrial Revolution it's
here whether we like it or not and it's
amazing how resistant people can be
across organizations and across
Industries but we're all in and have
been quite public about that our aim is
to provide daily decision intelligence
to give people a sort of nudge in the
right direction to give them deeper
insights to allow them to be more
effective for what they do and and it's
real and it's such a privilege to be
involved in it I mean you're you're
taking a very aggressive active stance
what surprised you well a lot of things
surprise you about AI I mean for some
people it's Skynet and Terminator right
for some people it's they confuse AI
with cyber I'm not saying everything is
perfect but I
I'm surprised that the number of CEOs or
Executives who their first response to
an i AI conversation is governance
controls rules principles of course
everything has its place but I think we
have to be honest with ourselves if it
is the fourth Industrial Revolution
which we believe it is then
hesitating uh this fear that can take
over can deprive you of so much
opportunity and you have to go for it I
find that when you talk to lots of CEOs
they really are very hesitant right
someone say even frightened I look
internally people are frightened that
you get this radical data transparency
you can see their data real time and and
you're experiencing that I've
experienced that and still do you know
people are often shocked that you may
get the Insight at the same time as
somebody lower down the
organization and then there's a lost
opportunity to polish a slide deck and
represent it in the way that I'm
supposed to be informed it's not a
deliberate sort of misleading approach
it's it's what people know they get the
Insight they craft the story they push
it upwards and that's life in many
corporations for us we get the data I
get the same data at every level of the
organization does I get the Insight
exactly the same time right and then
people say Paul don't look the data is
not 100% correct we make it correct
because the data is live M so if you
really jump in and make it correct it'll
better reflect what you're doing right
but if we wait for Perfection it's
simply not going to happen right so so
we're seeing fear and and some of that I
guess is not unreasonable you know we we
read reports about the impact on job
losses for example to come from AI I
wonder what mindset you believe people
need to adopt in the workforce of all
generations as they approach or we all
approach this new future you know the
the uh the adoption of AI in particular
is not about jobs and I know people will
think that and inevitably more
meaningful works created and of course
some roles change or some skills don't
match and therefore you know with the
help of many of the people in the room
you get to reshape
organizations but in the end it's really
about using artificial intelligence to
create this real momentum of decision
making and and to be able to take such a
an advantage over the
competition and we believe I believe
that if you create more meaningful work
and people focus on insights and action
and less on Excel and PowerPoint and
word then there is a chance that they
enjoy their work more now it may lead to
productivity gains it may lead to
efficiency it may lead to all those
things nobody's sort of denying that but
what I've discovered so far is when it
does people see it quite quickly and
they put their hand up to do something
else or to focus more on insights than
interpret than than um data crunching
right and aggregation you know I'm old
enough to remember when uh the internet
was launched you know
commercially and sort of similar
arguments even when the cell phone was
launched be careful um but the truth is
they made all our lives better the use
cases are coming but I think we're
starting to understand now how how much
this is going to change everybody's
lives so so who's leading this in the
organization is it a new generation is
it specially appointed people is it you
know where's the leadership coming from
it's an excellent question because maybe
I'm the last of the of the great
dinosaur CEOs who got to the Top by
doing sort of every job I ran Japan I
ran North America you know I was in
Global Marketing you know I've done all
the tasks I get to the top and then I've
sort of seen everything
and so I can be involved in every
discussion and now the younger Talent
are saying you didn't see AI old man so
you know I have a better Insight than
you do and oh and by the way I'm not
just going to push it up to my boss I'd
like to tell you myself right so the
younger Talent justifiably is saying hey
you know I don't need to have my work
shared upwards by a bunch of guys mhm
who are all sitting there going what do
you think and none of them actually know
and so we invert the pyramid we have to
have different people with 2 three four
years experience in the room because
what do we know and that's sort of
exciting I think really exciting so is
AI a unique disruptor if we think about
some of the other big challenges you
know we've got a shift the entire global
economy to be sustainable for example is
that comparable in terms of complexity
maybe more so how do you tackle that
kind of an issue I think these are these
are the big transformational moments for
society and you know uh sustainability
is you know for many it was uh carbon
neutrality then it was Net Zero it was
go to cop 28 it was but a poster by the
elevator with the meaningful work you're
doing to right to show your commitment
but it's really different now I think
there's a a collective realization
certainly in healthcare
that we didn't do well enough and we're
a very purpose-- driven organization
right and so an industry in fact we do
Health we transform the practice of
medicine we invent Miracles often and so
it's very easy to say look we're very
Purpose
Driven but it doesn't abdicate the
responsibility of removing plastic from
packaging of vaccines and medicines it's
ridiculous to even think you wouldn't
have to often it's harder with the
regulator by the way way to get that
done then with your own people so you
you've got those kinds of projects going
on have you could give us an examp we
have to we have to do it we have to do
it because you know we have this sort of
approach of um what can we do that if we
don't do it won't happen right and
that's sort of our philosophy you know
in healthcare is a good example you know
the healthcare delivery of healthare
creates more carbon than the airline
industry and that's half of that let's
say 5% half of that is making drugs
shipping them doing different things the
other half is people driving to
hospitals for an appointment in an
overheated overcooled Healthcare
practice too often without the use of a
virtual hybrid delivery of healthcare
and it's the same as the airline
industry and you know we feel because
we're in healthcare we have this unique
opportunity if somebody's pre-diabetic
for example and you coach them and they
change their lifestyle and don't become
a diabetic that's the difference of them
creating 16 tons of carbon as a normal
adult healthy and 48 tons of carbon in
their adult life if they become diabetic
that's a
3X that's really meaningful and if we
don't step in and help we just simply
never get there and we're doing a lot of
work I'm doing a lot of work with King
Charles and the sustainable markets
initiative right to get people to
decarbonize the delivery of healthcare
because it's such a massive opportunity
and presumably you've got to collaborate
in very different ways than in the past
to do you know you're talking about
Supply chains to deal with something
like plastic are you seeing different
kinds of skills from people in order to
make those collaborations well I think
the these functions and the
sustainability groups as said have gone
from a poster by the elevator to being
very actively involved in a lot of work
to do these things properly and you know
you it's not about a competitive
advantage in Noy being better at
Wastewater management or renewable
energy than fisa or Astro zenica that's
not a competition right the competition
is US versus you know destroying the
planet right so we work a lot together
to do the right thing I work with Nova
nordis astroica GSK to try and work out
ways to be kinder to the environment in
the delivery of Health it's the right
thing to do right it's a shared
responsibility Collective responsibility
and we're talking here about big Social
Challenges Beyond anyone business or
industry or even country with a
expectation that business needs to step
forward I think partly driven by the
fact that policy doesn't always work and
we're disappointed with leadership and
disappointed with government so's a lot
of finger pointing as to who's
responsible and who can act on these big
shifts I wonder how uh ambitious and
bold do you feel CEOs should be about
stepping forward and helping Society
through some of these Mega transitions
that we are faced with you know it's
it's it's clear that that um companies
are being pulled more into the
conversation about individuals values
and um I think people who work in our
company and old companies start to try
and identify themselves perhaps rightly
with the values of the company and
they're starting to have much higher
expectations about the company they work
for and it can be on all the major
social issues you know there's been so
many difficult moments and tragic
moments I'm often written to by people
from all over the world you haven't
declared which side you're on on this
important subject why
not and people want to know that you are
fully invested the company is behind
them to be clear it's almost impossible
to get everything right the world is
almost I you know perfectly divided you
can pick an issue and half your
employees will tell you we we don't
agree and the other half will say Well
done and we're not used to that as CEOs
we're used to trying to find the right
sort of moment to get the majority to
say I'm proud of my company so you have
to retreat a little bit and say I'll
spend my energy on making sure whatever
the issue that the people 990,000 people
in our case get the very best chance to
live their best version of themselves
could be inclusion it could be race it
could be many different things uh it
could be lgbtq plus but whatever those
issues that are being debated strongly
or less strongly in different parts of
the world it matters to us that our
people feel they can be the best version
of themselves so when people ask what do
you think about this and what do you
think about that I can have a personal
opinion but our organization if you're
looking to match your values with ours
is really about we're in healthcare we
want you to have the best life possible
how can the company facilitate that in
this sort of malstrom of subjects and we
focus there and I'm not saying we're
perfect I don't think any company really
is perfect on this but the expectation
of our own employees to be able to set a
standard on an issue and to see it
through is real and leading in these
times is more complicated I think than
perhaps it has been previously so you're
you're describing a world where the work
of the CEO is changing very fast um
could you just sum up for us the role of
a leader in this new
era well I took this role at the end of
2019 and thought I will roll through my
100 day plan and I will amble through
getting around town halls across the
world and shake a lot of hands and do a
listening tour and a pandemic dropped on
us within a few weeks after that and
worked out of uh the kitchen uh not far
from here and the war Russia Ukraine
current War uh Israel uh and
Hamas and uh mentioned the pandemic
China us uh the social
issues and I think what we realize is
leading is I think put somebody
described it as the the Perma crisis you
know a sort of you know a Cadence of
issues that just is Relentless right and
you you really have to have some
resiliency leading now I think and you
have to recognize that there are a
series of Sprints in the role there's
the fundamentals of the business that
must be continued then there's a
metronome for us we feel the
responsibility to bring medicines and
transformational medicines forward is
non-negotiable at the same time parts of
your organization is in a very difficult
situation somewhere in the world right
and we have to make sure we have the
right energy experts support crisis
teams often more recently right to to
protect our people and to continue the
work we do we ship drugs all over the
world irrespective of The Stance of um
politics or anything else people are
people and if the sick will help but it
really has got very complicated so
resiliency agility U being open-minded
recognizing you're not the expert many
times trusting the advice you get from
your own people particularly those on
the ground protecting your people where
it's necessary moving your people where
it's necessary that's the sort of new
expectation right really I mean I think
we're all experiencing this sense of
permac Crisis just to finish it' be
great to to just get a sense of what do
you really excited about right
now well I'm I'm incredibly excited I
touched on at the beginning about the
use of artificial intelligence
particularly large language
models CU I think it changes everything
it's got me questioning whether I can go
back and look at medicines that didn't
quite make it and wonder if we just
didn't know enough with the data that we
had to look deep enough it can be you
know recently we got we just did our
this is a small example but it's just
fun our engagement survey we had uh
409,000 uh comments 9 million words and
normally somebody would make a nice
slide deck to tell me the organization
Paul is very engaged never been more
engaged how much more engage 0.1 okay
good thank you definitely
Improvement and so I asked them to run
the 49,000 comments through a large
language model 40 minutes later it told
me the three things that people love
about the company three things that
people hate about the
company I didn't need a lot of external
support didn't need teams of people and
it was clear it was no hallucination
because it was there right in front of
me and it made sense and I shared them
with people and they're like yeah that's
us
and I think that's the difference
between meaningful work using let's talk
about what it tells us about whether our
people really like it here and bring
their best or not I think AI for me a
relatively new CEO I have a chance to
disrupt structural biology
electromicroscopy I have a chance to
invent medicines and undruggable targets
that were never touched before I have a
chance to take away the sort of I should
put it the heavy lifting unglamorous
work that people don't like doing have a
chance to reinvent everything to do it
more efficiently reinvest in R&D and
have a chance to get ahead of the
competition while they're all wor
worrying we have governance right but
every step forward by us is a step of
leaving behind those that are overly
sensitive and we're happy to share but
we can do incredible things for patients
and for the people in the company by
being more bold about stepping into the
new world your passion is infectious
thank you thank you very much Paul great
to